hello and welcome to video playing three
Treena arrow okay and ask him about what
he does against the Petrov and go Steve
one is a popular way to play why did
it's not really all that dangerous but
it is it is okay right oftentimes place
with Queen f4 in such a situation now
even now like immediately this is the
most popular booth is it going for
castling alone there would be quite
unusual
each home is some trying to prevent g5
what I'm hoping is with Bishop e6 that
he will play Bishop d3 after which g5
just work yeah
it's a funny little tactic based on age
takes 3 5 HD HD 5 when both h1 rook and
Queen will hang castling long is very
unusual in this in this kind of this
kind of formation black is normally
quite well equipped jam with the center
being as strong as it is okay I should
probably go for queenside castling
myself what I to wonder is if that is
enough really like being very ambitious
d4 25 or is that too much it is
definitely very ambitious but let's try
and a queen defy of threatening made in
one it's always tempting but he will go
b3 and you don't quite know if you have
gained much maybe I can do that I'm a
threatening Bishop takes a two and this
position I don't think so
that's a very relaxed way of playing it
isn't isn't it isn't that dangerous
it looks dangerous I thought now like b3
is mandatory
see how many move and then I play for I
wouldn't have allowed that with white of
course he can play Bishop a4 now or
Bishop c4 but then I go to the 7 and I'm
coming from the AJ with the Queen so
that is kind of okay I guess I have not
yet cancelled and my king is still on
yet but I know it feels quite safe
though you Queen takes this kind of
automatic almost I guess so don't think
for politics looks wrong
yeah I like this pollution I've made
them quite a good progress on the
queenside already and I don't see much
of counter play here
so Bishop seven I guess I need I need
the h8 work so I have to cancel or
alternatively came to d7
this is also an idea why not I mean you
cannot go g5 and shut it down taking
looks fine for me as well and you know
you know that looks like a good good
move that's good for black doesn't have
a really good reply look she won maybe
yeah I can simply take it
- I have something else no it's okay
it's totally okay to do that okay let's
take this and now maybe even rook h3
intending now to sacrifice it's not not
such a bad idea I have to move queen g6
check by the way just I just recognize
that this is on the cards that's
something I should have seen a bit
earlier
okay well reacting to my idea would be
nice I mean that must work I didn't
calculate that but that must be made
cannot believe it isn't
that was really really nice him I got a
really nice position right out of the
opening
yeah this this line you with details e5
has become somewhat popular in recent
years not because it is so fantastic for
white but because the conventional ways
against the petrov are just not leading
anywhere so people tried that for
example it but what was playback we
shocked and we took off in recent games
like in the Berlin candidates and in the
grain cutter namond right afterwards
against karana karana once took on the -
that was a bishop game and he played
remarkable Queen d7 against which akov
don't dare me to explain what that does
don't really know I do understand that
this move is the playable of course
crucial was even winning the game later
I guess we took off but this is like
normal
let's take it yeah and c5 this is all
very very standard but I don't think why
this and any what doesn't really have
any good hope here for an advantage I
think blacks central control and good
development should be always fine h6
yeah he went age form who should be six
note that here I cannot play g5 the
problem is that after takes takes Knight
takes there's the made threats and this
is not hanging with a check if after
Bishop d6 white would go here I will
play g5 and I would be a lot better the
engine gives c4 first but it doesn't
make a difference really the issue is
that now there's this trick like I'm
attacking this will check and the queen
is hanging and the Queen cannot protect
the weak so white loses immediately here
it's a nice little trick okay
Heba you castles long that looks
dangerous for white I mean okay I went
with this as I mentioned ambitious move
before the
the angular engine just like that that's
good of course I came just to play
Bishop d7 27 something like that but
that is an ambitious trine King begone
yeah if five they're not necessary maybe
but it worked out beautifully because he
did not react in any way I mean my idea
was kind of clear I want to play Queen D
5 B 3 a 4 and he didn't record
just play the normally of with Bishop d3
and I mean no you have to somehow I mean
it's not so easy in blitz of course and
I miss opponent's ideas all the time but
it's a good idea to try to figure out
really what what was a 5 about what was
what was blacks idea and my idea was
exactly that and now I get the F and
open very quickly and you should have
tried to prevent it so here
you know the engine gives before and
that is the best move then white is in
deep trouble I have to before black is
better in many ways ok until the engine
once wants me to take on b3 first and
then click Bishop soon okay yeah I
didn't really have before on the Raider
but it is just it's pretty terrible
anyway
yeah here um just castling would lead to
a winning attack but yeah h5 is not bad
it keeps a big advantage it's not as
good as directly attacking though so and
then we gauge 3 is strong and
threatening boss you okay - Andrew P 3
and he didn't react to it I think f3 was
the only move and then I mentioned there
is a check that's something that I
recognize relatively late one thing is
that if he goes king be tuned it's like
this is not I mean it was a okay move
but if the rook would have plays just
like a little bit differently but let's
say the king is only 70 and I have this
idea that's what I'm trying to say check
and then I just need a rope here for
mate next but I don't quite get it in
there is just it's too far away
if the King would be here or the rook
already here and then I could get it to
a eight and we would win it's funny that
this is a draw you know okay I wouldn't
have played to sacrifice a but it's very
very close to working so you can for
example think about a move like let's
let's say King e7 and that would
threaten Queen g6 King b2 and so on so
if white would do an on move and this is
this is happening I just wanted to show
you this idea but then this is winning
it's just doesn't cannot be stopped yeah
well but he did react at all but the
position was very bad here okay to us
he's killing killing white like this one
and there should be a maid again I
didn't really calculate it here made
into AB D 3 is made in one okay this is
also made in one okay yeah thanks a lot
for watching guys